10 years
[Music]
live chat
thank you Tom
good evening everybody and welcome to
this evening's meeting of the external
overview scrutiny committee and today's
Wednesday 15th of March thank you all
for coming those that are here and thank
you to our guests that are zooming in
um we'll start going through the agenda
before we move on to tonight's
presentation
apologies for absence card
[Music]
thank you Karen we're going to move on
to the minutes of the last meeting which
we won't be able to vote on this evening
as we are not called tonight but I don't
think there was anybody in particular
um actions we can check them accuracy
and take a vote
thank you
notes
oh yeah okay so I'll take the page
numbers of the fortune if that's aware
of everyone so I'm going to start on
page three
page four
and on page five the letter went to rmp
the WBC copyright is it just mean just
you just I can forward it out if you'd
like
thank you thank you Karen Page Six
page seven
age eight
and page nine is just for me to sign
anybody for any comments
I'm really happy to know those for this
evening and then we can yeah
thank you
um I'm gonna go on to public
participation no public tonight
and then on to the action list
I think it's pretty much
um Southwest water presentation that's
still really ongoing
and a copy of the report Dentistry still
haven't had anything solid from anybody
in particular
um I did email
absolutely Linda Hellyer and she didn't
tell us any different from what we
already know to be honest so that is
something that we still need to
um look into because there's still a
shortage
[Music]
counselor Penningtons is complete which
was the letter to our MP Jeffrey Cox
oh I've never met with Adrian Avery in
cancer laws and councilor Hopson whoever
they met
up
yeah I don't know if they met
I've not had any feedback on that
okay that's it um
action points
moving on to item number five which is
decorations of Interest members with
interested refer to your gender items
and describe the nature of their
interest when the item is considered
item number six agreement at the agenda
part one and part two we've only got
part one to vote
urgent matters brought forward with
permission of the chair I don't have any
okay so now we're gonna move on to the
main spot tonight and here we have
Sahara hide and Catherine Palin and
they're going to give us an update on
we're on Partners in the health
regarding integration of the northern
Devon Healthcare trust and the world
denim Exeter Foundation
um including our future Hospital
programs so ladies I don't know if you
can still hear me
yep yep
okay
thank you
great so we've got a really short
presentation but hopefully it will bring
you up to speed and I'm just I'd just
like to start by saying thank you so
much for inviting us back
um it's really important to us that we
we make sure the community are informed
about what the NHS is doing so so thank
you for this um you are very assiduous
in in giving us appointments to to come
and talk to us so my name is Catherine
Allen I'm the director of strategy for
the Royal Devon University healthcare
trust
um but I've worked in North Devon for
about 15 years
um and Zara if I ask you to introduce
yourself as well
yes I'm Zara Hyde I'm currently holding
the poster director of Estates and
facilities at the trust but my core
interest in the new hospital design
program director for the our future
Hospital project
great thank you so we've got a few uh
I'll go first and then I'll hand over to
Zara and if you would like to we can
break in the middle after my bit and
then move on or do questions at the end
it's entirely up to you but uh just
please interrupt us if you if you'd like
to raise a point so if I could ask for
the next slide please
so yes and and we can move on
next slide please
great so we call uh the merger of the
northern Devon Healthcare trust and the
Royal Devon and Exeter Foundation trust
and integration because obviously the
sizes of the trusts is really different
but we didn't want it to feel like a
takeover so I just wanted to make that
point that we call it an integration
when it but it's technically a merger of
two organizations so before when we last
met you we hadn't we hadn't merged but
we were well on the way to doing so and
our conversation when we last spoke to
you was about what we hope to achieve
when we merged
um with a with a local NHS partner and
really back then uh we were we would
have told you that we were hoping that
the merger would give us strength from a
larger trust so North Devon would gain
strength from the support of a larger
partner East would learn from The
Innovation and Agility of a smaller
trust so North Devon has a really good
reputation as a quite a Nimble
um Nimble trust due to its size and then
you know it's not um it's not a secret
to say the NHS is suffering for some
resilience issues in its services so we
are we we are experiencing challenges
with recruitment challenging with um
Workforce Supply and these are all
causing resilience issues to our
services so we hope that by bringing our
services together we'd be able to
combine our resources better and there's
also about
um also there's a case for reducing the
unnecessary duplication so both trusts
have things that we do twice so by by
bringing them together we could do it
once and for all so
um that that was really important to us
and also
um the patient confidence in access to
local Services I think that the feeling
of confidence that you get when you're
working on something with us with a
partner it um really the community
really felt that so that was that's
really good that was one of our benefits
and then there's really important things
that Arginine are really strong at which
is about you know research and
Innovation and um you know it's part
it's a host for the Genome Project so
accessing that for the population of
North Devon because research
um services that invest in research are
are benefit to patients so patients in
North Devon would never have had access
to trials before so by joining with rdne
that we we we can bring that benefit to
patients locally
so next slide please
uh so here's the acid test did we do
that so as you will probably be aware
murders take a while
um they're you know there's two cultures
that you bring together and there's um
there's lots of lots of systems that you
have to align um and so on so we're
pretty much in the in the weeds of that
at the moment so we did a lot of it
before we merged because we've been
working with rdne for three years but
that's still ongoing but I just wanted
to highlight a couple of things that
we're pretty proud of that we've managed
um to to date that I can talk to in more
detail so the first one is about
clinical resilience so one of the really
important things was about stabilizing
our clinical community in north and
we've developed plans that that do that
now achieving them is is is the next
thing that we've got to do but we are we
have proof we have developed plans that
increase the medical work or hope to
increase the medical Workforce in north
and we're now marketing those posts
really heavily across our networks
across the country
so that's the first thing that we feel
we've made really good progress in the
second one is in joint working
so we are sharing capacity patients in
North Devon are accessing capacity down
in East our DNS Eastern patients are
coming up and having operations up in
North so we are finding that we are able
to share capacity and that's really
important if you think about the size of
the NHS waiting list making use of all
of our resources to the benefits of our
patients across North and East Evans
really important
and then the other thing that we said we
needed as we merged is to be on a common
platform so patient records so
um in layman's terms all of the times
you come to an outpatient appointment we
record all that and we record the
Diagnostics and we record the outcomes
having that shared across
um what is now a common Workforce so
that no matter where you are in east or
North Devon as a patient the same
clinical team can access your your your
patient record and and
um it means if you ever have to go down
to Exeter to have care that Specialist
Care the same the clinical team can see
your North Devon record as well so that
was really important and that's a
multi-million pound investment in in the
NHS in Devon so that's we're really
really pleased about that because it
will mean lots of benefits are possible
and then we start as services are coming
together we're starting to see there
that we are putting joint nursing and
medical
liaise and what that means is you just
get a common clinical oversight and
Leadership for a service across Northern
East Devon so we think about patients as
a as a whole population as opposed to
just north and just East so that's
really really beneficial
uh and then we've been challenged
recently as you know with covid but more
laterally with industrial action and flu
and norovirus and actually working
together and sharing that response is
really it has has been improved in real
strength so um making really good plans
together and sharing them is is has been
proved really important and then culture
so um as you can imagine North Devon is
very different to our DNA we've got
different histories we've got a
different Legacy we've got different
approaches and different styles but
actually bringing them together
um you know we've got a we've got a
strategy that's called better together
you'll see it at the bottom and I think
that's in recognition of the fact that
approaching something with diversity
means you make better decisions at the
end so we are on that Journey it's it's
going to be different you get different
pockets of different cultures within the
same organization so I'm not saying
we're you know there isn't um we're not
quite there yet but I think um you know
that Journey started
um and then the other the last thing um
really to say is that one of the
benefits of bringing an organization
together is you start looking at things
differently and together so we are we
are developing digital strategies and
estate strategies of which Zara May
touch on in a minute and people
strategies and finance strategies so it
just means you have a you you know the
population benefits from an organization
that has a real clear plan and what it
you know and a sense of what it's going
to deliver
so that's my update as as you know as
you probably expect a merger that's not
even a year old yet there's you know
there are green shoots
um of progress but it will take you know
we know it's going to take a long time
and that was really our aim that it
didn't we didn't rock the boat we we
kept things going as they were without
much radical change
so I'm I'm done with my bit I think
um but I'm happy to either break now and
ask questions answer questions or we can
do that at the end it's entirely up to
you but it's over to Zara
if not that's your questions now or at
the end yeah be better yeah
and so just in case there was um
something off now that we wouldn't ask
for if that's okay yes that's absolutely
fine so um I'll carry on then so as
Catherine said
um the focus
um for the new hospital program uh which
is there I'm responsible for
um similarly in some ways to the merger
um it takes time I think that probably
is a key message today uh it's probably
just worth reminding
um people listening into this in terms
of what the new hospital program is
about
um because it has already been going on
for some two and a half years but in
2019 uh the government announced 3.7
billion in the period to 2025 which is
the current funding cycle we're in and
that was a combination of building some
of the new hospitals that identified but
also seed funding to help design and get
ready to build the next role class of
new hospitals which included North Devon
District Hospital our society in
Barnstable and in July 2021 we shared
with you the fact that we're putting our
strategic outline case to our board
which have been approved and forwarded
to the National program
um interestingly that was based on three
major premises is that a case for change
the fact that our estate is aging our
hospitals built in the 1970s at some of
the older parts are definitely reaching
a point where they are very hard and
expensive to maintain Although our
estate seem to do an amazing job and the
current capacity is going to cause
limitations in the future because our
population is continuing to grow and as
it grows of course we need more services
and we need the estate in which to
deliver those and then the final premise
was the fact that we do as Catherine
alluded to have challenges with
Workforce shortages out we need to make
sure that we make North Devon a really
attractive place to work so when we set
out on this journey that was our goal
okay next slide please
so essentially we set out with a very
clearly stated ambition which was around
the fact that we wanted to invest in our
local hospital and we want to provide
modern connected care so that refers to
both our digital and our building
ambition we wanted to improve the
working environment for our staff and we
wanted to ensure high quality emergency
and Specialist Care for Northern Devon
both now and in the future and our
estimates looked out to 2035 in terms of
our population changes so this was quite
a long-term Vision next slide please
so the Strategic outline case had three
stages to it the first stage fulfilled
that ambition to look after our staff
and to attract the workforce we needed
and to retain them which is a very
important objective and by
reprovisioning some of our oldest estate
we believed we would be able to do that
the second phase looks at building the
brand new
um estate which includes our operating
theaters and some of our other
facilities which are very much um
towards the end of their lifetime under
the areas where we now spend most of our
maintenance budget so around those CSS
we will build the day case facilities
for patients uh moving looking at our
Women's and Children's and our intensive
care services where again those are
housed in extremely oldest state and
then the third phase is to refurbish
what is left because our main tower
block is an extremely sound structure
and I wouldn't want anyone to think
otherwise but the infrastructure inside
of it is very old and therefore
refurbishing and repurposing gives us
both the best for healthcare but also
the best from a sustainability
carbon release point of view so that was
the three phases we identified next
slide please
so where are we now
um we are awaiting the outcome of the
government discussions which have been
going on for several months now because
this is a huge decision as you can
imagine
um and in the current times that we Face
nevertheless both the Prime Minister and
the chancellor have been really clear in
reiterating their commitment to the new
hospital program and the creation of 40
new and redeveloped Hospital sites so
that has been a positive for us
throughout but we are now reaching the
point where budget day has just just
arrived and the commitment has been
repeated so what we hope to hear very
shortly is confirmation of that level of
investment there are some challenges
that have come along in the meantime
with some hospitals that are using
materials uh reinforce their rated
concrete some people may have read about
which has added to the burden of Estates
rebuild but the government is very
excited in that and has been very clear
still in their commitment we are what's
called a cohort for project so that
means that we will be a pilot for the
new standardized designs that Lord
Markham and his team have been promoting
and that is all about trying to get best
value for the public purse by building
as much as possible to standardize
designs but also to help the industry
because building on this scale is huge
for British industry the British
construction industry will be stretched
massively and therefore standardized
designs help them to help us to build
quickly and more effectively the focus
for the last six months has been very
much around supporting the developments
of the newly merged trust Catherine
alluded to the Strategic work so our
team has supported the development of
the joint clinical strategy again
assuring alignment with the original our
future Hospital program but also now
looking at our Estates and digital
strategies to ensure that when we do put
in our detailed designs they have very
clearly aligned to the direction the
trust wants to go in and we've also done
a lot of Engagement we've continued to
work with one Northern Devon and prior
to Christmas we ran a session with
Partners in one Northern Devon looking
at the benefits of The Wider economic
benefits to our society in this area of
constructing the new hospital and for
modernizing our health care facilities
and it was a really really energetic
session so we were really pleased to
have that opportunity to involve and
engage our partners in what is something
that will for us as the largest employer
in the area have a massive impact and
then finally obviously patient
experience
and staff experience has been the
subject of a number of particular
service surveys to understand better how
we can develop the services of the
future in a way that really resonates
with what people are experiencing now
and what they what matters to them so
that's the important area and then
finally we've been recruiting our
Champions across the trust which are
staff members across all areas that will
help us to engage with our wider staff
when we get to the point of being able
to start our detailed designs on the
Estates front we also haven't Stood
Still there have been some Capital
opportunities that have come our way and
we have seized those when they've
arrived so before Christmas we had the
opportunity to redevelop an area of
space inside the main building to create
a same-day emergency care facility and
this is really important because it
avoids are missing people unnecessarily
to hospital it allows GPS and others to
Route patients straight to hospital for
Diagnostics and for consultation and
then be able to be sent home before the
end of the day it's the same day
Emergency Care enables us to process
urgent care in a different way and
enables us to also manage the flow of
urgent Emergency Care through the
hospital much better her it opened on
the 27th of December and within the
first 24 hours we'd had 20 patients go
through so I think the staff were really
pleased to have that facility but the
patients were also really positive about
the experience and then finally we've
just now been the beneficiaries of an
additional Capital sum to enable us to
invest in a new discharge Lounge which
will be a purpose-built area to enable
us to start the process of discharge
with patients earlier in the day by
being able to move them to a comfortable
and safe place where they can have their
meds prescribed have their final checks
and be collected by relatives and others
and discharged home and that again
enables us to support flow through the
hospital which you'll all have read
about some of the challenges the NHS has
faced this is our way of managing that
well and we have sized that to be fit
for future as well as current use so
we're very pleased about that
opportunity we do it expect to be asked
to develop an more detailed and business
case probably not going to be for
another few months yet but the
announcements we're expecting will help
us to prepare for that and also enable
us to start re-engaging with some of our
partners on what will be involved in
that details design it's going to be a
year to 18 months of extremely hard work
but hopefully will give us a really
clear and robust design for the future
Hospital
next slide please
so um questions first then and then I'm
going to come back and and suggest some
ways in which you can help us but I
think let's hear from you first of all
right
yes please
thank you um
independent person not non-posing member
um can I ask probably Catherine
um can I draw you a little bit on the
program for the developments of the
north Devon hospital
um when do you expect you know to
actually start on site then and
follow-up question to that is is it
going to be built on the existing site
where it is now in basketball thank you
do you want me to answer Kathy yeah
um so I'll answer that one um so our
build window was to start in 2025 and we
haven't moved that build window because
a lot of the work around centralized
design has been about speeding up the
design process so that we'll be ready to
build
um there may be some small adjustments
we have to wait and see but at the
moment that is the planning window we've
been working to is breaking ground on
site in 2025. the three-phase
development is specifically because we
are using our existing Hospital site uh
partly because if I were brutally honest
we don't have a level of funding that
would enable us to build a complete new
hospital and therefore redeveloping our
existing facilities offers the best
value for money and we have come up with
a design approach that will enable us to
complete what will approximately be
about two to two and a half years of
work but it will be all done while the
hospital is still operating in its
existing mode so each stage has been
plan so that we can maintain and
continue services to our local
population whilst we are preparing each
phase of the build
thank you
and
then
welcome councilor evening conference
6 30 start yeah
[Music]
I did
check on my own agenda you're not the
only one
all right
it doesn't say 6 30 online
basically
knocked out in the hospital with one
engine of the town really I mean and
it's a devil together especially uh um
if you're in an emergency and you want
to get through the town and have you got
any thoughts on podcasts
somewhere there's more approachable at
the main hospital and have a different A
and E part but uh this this one's what
you thought
um obviously when we do the options
appraisal we have to consider all the
options
um and clearly obviously the sighting of
the hospital which is a historic
situation
um is not necessarily ideal for
everybody and even the fact it's out of
town
um Can itself create some transport
difficulties however as I was saying
earlier within the financial envelope
that has been notionally allocated there
is no way we could construct a complete
freestanding hospital and from our
patient flow management perspective we
cannot separate our hot emergency and
acute care from our surgical facilities
not just because it uses the same
Workforce but also because of the need
to have those facilities so we have at
North Devon the minimum combined
facility you would need for Urgent and
emergency care we do obviously still do
some planned elective work as well so
you could always argue you could
separate that out but then of course our
patients can choose now in this newly
merged world to have their um their
elective operations their choice
operations and planned operations are at
different sites for instance at the
Nightingale or indeed at one foot so for
some people that might actually pose a
better solution than coming out to the
north Devon hospital I say that without
any sort of judgment on the transport
links but the reality is for some people
that may be easier Catherine's going to
now add some add some properties about
in that
is that basically
um Staffing um is there going to be a
problem
getting stopping for food hospitals or
do you enforcing that being a university
hospital it will be run a lot of
training
I think there's definitely a case for
being able to Market
um working in the trust differently now
uh now we're now we're emerged trust
with associations with the University of
Exeter the University of Plymouth it's a
much bigger teaching hospital that we're
now linked with as and I was saying in
my earlier Con in my earlier
presentation the research you know rdna
is a really active research trust and
that means you bring up clinical trials
which then means your clinicians take
part in those clinical trials and they
get a different they can develop their
roles differently so we think we are
working really hard to Market those
roles and those opportunities to people
to attract them to come down to this
beautiful part of the world
um but everyone's doing it the whole of
the NHS is doing it and you know I I I
speak with the backdrop of the
industrial action that's going on today
we we know there are issues with supply
of Workforce to the NHS and we're doing
the best we can
thank you
sorry I was just confirming yes yes
um
[Music]
is there any evidence
is
already having an effect and attracting
people to the area or is it true
um
so anything I offer be anecdote so no it
is it is exciting the staff that work
here
which means that we don't lose them but
I haven't spoken to individuals who
um are particularly attracted by that
but that that doesn't mean they don't
exist I just personally don't know of
any examples but you know Zara May
a major issue across the country are you
aware of how our figures are compared to
other hospitals in other areas I mean
are we calling on it
forced out from our hospitals going to
be agencies at the post getting
full-time dogs I mean have you got any
information about that
I can definitely send you data after
this but um but I do know that we we
spend a lot of money in Devon on agency
staff and we are proportionately higher
Spenders on that um comparatively to
other areas now there's been a lot of
work understanding why that is it could
be our rurality it could be a variety of
factors but I you know I'm really happy
to provide that evidence to you
um later but our efforts are to reduce
the amount if we can on the amount we
spend on agency
yeah okay
whatever it was going electronic
um
how did it go or how is it going
great so yes it launched um North Devon
went on to the same system as Arden in
July 2022
um and
um actually because because North was
already on a electronic system of sorts
um the transition was was really good so
I think the system is embedded there are
now two teams two clinical teams one in
each one in North who are working
together on the same system and that has
um that is proving beneficial
um it means that clinicians that come up
to from from East Devon to North Devon
have the same record the patients that
they see across both sites are on the
same record and all of that information
is there so that's proving really
beneficial there's some other things
that are happening that are in in
infancy given the short time span um but
things like Central triage points so a
you know patients being referred into a
particular service are getting triaged
by any clinician across North and East
Devon so that means that patients are
getting quicker quicker part you know
their their onward referral into the
hospital is being done quicker because
they're being seen doesn't matter
whether it's a North or an East Devon
um consultant so that's hopefully more
of that sort of thing will be happening
um as as everyone gets used to the
system and starts exploring the benefits
thank you
thank you only just on the building
um assuming it does happen is there any
um will there be an impact on where uh
patients Go I mean for instance and when
the building starts are patients likely
to have to go to Exeter for more during
the build phase or will they be still
able to go to North Devon as they would
normally
so the way in which you plan the project
is as I was saying earlier to maintain
our services at current levels
throughout and the way we're going to do
that just to be very clear is by
building the new build facilities
parallel to and we are looking at how
we're going to traffic manage around the
site along with colleagues in North
Devon District Council to understand how
we can increase access to the site so we
don't inconvenience patients and other
essential traffic through construction
traffic but the actual build itself will
be on an area which is currently
um staff car parking which will have
been redesignated and the car Parks
moved and therefore we will be able to
do the entire build while still
maintaining our normal hospital
operation and then when we switch over
Services we will then be able to do the
refurbishment at our own pace with the
remaining spaces so in terms of
disruption we have gone for what is
actually the most cost effective
solution minimal decant minimal
disruption
can I just add something to um
Catherine's answer earlier just because
it was on my mind around the um the
digital system for patients uh Records
um one of the areas that there's going
to be a big drive on shortly now um
which I'm quite excited about because it
will have an impact on the hospital use
is patient access uh so through a
patient portal and being able to pass
information to patients and patients
being able to feed back through their
own personalized access to their health
care it's not for everybody but there
are a code of people for whom that would
be very useful and helpful and again the
digital Vision that we had when we first
did the designs for the new hospital
assumed that we would need more capacity
but the amount of new capacity would
also take care of people
um accessing their health care in
different ways in the same way as we now
access travel and other things in
different ways
and thanks very much thank you anyways
also another question please um
the future would be for a medical
hospitals unit but there are other
specialized Services there what would be
the plan for that in the future
so we talking about did you say
Biddeford yeah Biddeford Hospital yeah
so all of the community
um hospitals are being reviewed at the
moment as part of our estate strategy
work and that's primarily because we
completed an estate survey uh back in
2020 2021 which looked at the condition
of all of our community estate and what
we would need to invest in each of the
estate to ensure it was fit for purpose
in the future but before we do any
investment what we wanted to identify is
the services in the future so firstly
we're evaluating its Community use in
terms of community teams so you probably
are aware of the hospital houses a
number of community teams that
effectively use it as their Hub out of
which to work it then also houses a
number of outpatient clinics and
services and it houses Therapy Services
all of which are a vital outside in the
community but what we want to make sure
is that if the facility
um in the future the facility is made
fit for purpose and he's used the best
effect and part of the economic benefits
Workshop we had before Christmas we were
challenged by colleagues in the primary
care networks as to how we were going to
work more closely with themselves and
other partners in our communities to use
our community estate well and to use it
to best effect and I think that's a good
challenge and one we welcome
thank you
thank you anybody that's in the leather
please yeah thank you good evening I'm
sorry I missed you and I was late coming
into this meeting I got it down at half
second Mindful and I apologize to the
chair and everybody and to you too for
your presentation
and I realized that he combined trust is
only 12 months old next month in April
it was only able to last year obviously
that the uh the new trust came to be but
prior to that until you've gone to see
if you've seen inspection at the
combined one yeah but they understand
that
but prior to that Northern District the
hospital there
was held on several aspects during the
CQC inspection in 2019 and the second
issues five percent acquiring
um
I'll say our services today that
requires Improvement or did our services
response with that required
foreign
and our resources used productively that
required Improvement and combine quality
and resource rating required Improvement
now I'm hoping you can give me some good
news on how things it develops and so
yeah so um as with all of the CTC
reports that trusts get there are
normally you know there are there are
good sides that you know there are
aspects that are really positive within
within the broad rating and I think
um
you're you're absolutely right to Flat
to highlight the fact that and we would
support everything that's written in the
the reports which are publicly available
um we felt that the CQC gave us a really
honest appraisal of of the situation
that they found when back in 2019
and I think that really
um at that time that really galvanized
us into thinking about what needed what
support was needed to such a really
isolated hospital and how some of the
diseconomies of scale that you have mean
that you know you just can't
um you don't have the resource and the
resilience to provide that sometimes to
provide the level of care that's
expected so I think there was a huge
amount of focus on that and um if I
remind you of the reason for the
collaborative agreement
um with ardeny back in 2018 which
slightly predates the CQC it was about
resilience and quality of care in North
Devon it was about leadership to North
Devon and it was about uh the third
one's just escaped me but it was kind of
in response to that to that CQC report
so
um we feel we've made lots of progress
since then obviously we've been through
the pandemic together which is
um which is you know really really
cemented some of those relationships and
yes you're right we haven't had a CPC
rating as a combined trust since then I
think one's imminent
um but I think I think they would find a
different picture
um not everything's put right
um you know there's still lots of
improvements that we need to make but I
feel I think I think we'd be in a really
different position now with the CQC
shows it and things have improved in
your opinion
yeah across a number of metrics I think
just the stabilization of the services
that have been possible some of our
highest risk services in any NHS trust
are your emergency care your cancer your
maternity care those things have had a
lot of work on them
um to address some of the issues that
were underlying it so yeah
okay thank you
thank you anybody else any further
questions
I've just got one piece of feedback but
um I'd like to thank you um I know a few
friends and colleagues that work within
the trust and they're working between
both sites so they're going for advanced
review to extra and they have commented
how the partnership is working well
because it's so different the way it's
operated
sorry Exeter as to what is the
Barnstable they feel whatever they're
learning their Exeter they are bringing
back to barnstables and I had some
really positive comments about the joint
partnership and the joint working
together so like I from what I hear
would like to think it's working really
well
yeah thank you that's really good to
hear because that's how we set it that's
how we that's what we set out to achieve
so I'm sort of my heart's warmed by that
a bit because
um approaching this is a merger and a
takeover really would have extinguished
that exploration wouldn't it so I'm
really pleased to hear that thank you
for giving us that feedback
you were saying that you want us to help
you so can you tell me what what is it
yeah so uh so um obviously as you can
appreciate the new hospital program is a
massive exercise for government it's not
the first time governments have tried it
but um on this scale and in this era uh
it's clearly the biggest project we've
seen and there is a danger there's a lot
on the plate so um the first thing I
probably say I would encourage you to
raise this uh with our local
representation in government your
concerns at the delay and your hope that
we will accelerate progress soon because
I think the more voices saying that the
better uh obviously uh trust executive
and our chair have raised their own
perspective on that but um the more
people out in the wider representation
uh of our people's views that are saying
the same thing in terms of just the the
need for clarity and certainty I think
one of the questions I asked earlier was
if the new hospital is built um I I'm
still sticking with the win but um
Knowing When would help us greatly so
the more people asking the question
um the more we're likely to get it
answered and the other thing is as we
move into this next phase we are going
to need to do a loss of Engagement this
is a big and complex project that will
affect all of us for years to come and
we want to do as much engagement as
possible so any thoughts or suggestions
you have about forums or areas where you
think it would be useful for us to start
to talk about what will be involved in
the new project and how people can get
involved we really welcome the fact that
you have a real Outreach into our
communities and we have used all those
that we've known of so far
um but obviously it's local councilors
who often sign posters to the places
where we can have good conversations and
get real feedback that helps to inform
it so I think you probably have the
contact for your chair with our comms
Department you can always email them
directly and we would welcome any
thoughts and ideas at this stage because
I think we're all committed to this
journey but
um it's just about making it as as good
as possible because this is a once in a
generation opportunity
oh thank you
um well basically we've got a bit of a
project in our local village where I
have multi-millionaire has been uh
taking over most of it and um
building and there was that Roar with
the locals and that until I decided uh
with a couple others of our attention
decided to do a committee where
they have meetings with them to updates
and I think you know that's the most
important thing people would like to
know how you're getting on and and an
update on how it emerges go into
buildings going Etc so I mean that that
would be a good thing
absolutely and we're really happy to
come out and talk to different groups
you know we are a small team but
nevertheless even in this holding
pattern mode we recognize that getting
people informed and knowledgeable about
what's coming helps us to get people
engaged when we start doing designs so
um everybody thinks you do the design at
the stage when you've got a picture of a
pretty building but the process of
getting to that picture of a pretty
building is just as important
um and I think in North Devon we have a
particularly through Northern Governor
um an Engaged Community our staff are
part of our community because obviously
many of our staffs friends and family
are users of our services that's what
happens with a really isolated hospital
but also um across the variety of
different communities we know there are
forums and opportunities that we can
maybe tap into so if you see a forum
you're thinking it'd be really helpful
if someone came and talked to them just
give us a shout
and if I can add to that as we get as
Zara gets closer to developing the
um outline the Strategic sorry the
business case
some of the benefits to the community
are going to become you know we're going
to have to articulate that and what was
really good about the session that we
held and people from torridge came is
the thought about how petrock needed to
help us with courses how our employers
needed to help us with Supply chains and
it was it just it just energized as Zara
said but I just wanted to sort of give
life to that it energized the people in
the room to think of the businesses that
would benefit from this so I just I
think that would be a really good area
of scrutiny for us just to make sure
that we articulate that back to the
community about how this is how this has
wider benefits not only to People's
Health from the actual Services provided
in it but the economy as well so that I
think that would be a really good thing
to come back and talk to you about later
[Music]
um
thank you anybody else any questions
um as a council we do have quite a few
um Avenues of communication ourselves
sure have you came up with so so um I
actually introduce myself I'm Sean
Connie I'm the head of Community Based
Victoria to a member of Staff problem
and the councilor
um yeah we we obviously communicate with
our parishes uh frequently and we have
our area advisory groups where we
connect with them so it's not really
interesting at some point for you to uh
to meet with those guys because that's
right down in the Grassroots of
democracy and talk to the first person
today they're right out here in their
community so I think have a good
um whilst I'm talking I'm I'm interested
I think you're connected into our North
Devon Futures program
um where we've been trying to think
about with North Devon Council uh how we
deliver services and what we want in
order from Devon to be like in them over
the next sort of up to 2050. I think
that's a really important
um piece of work for you guys to be
connected into because that's all about
the future of the area and it's an awful
lot of work but going on there around
skills provision I I'm interested I
think um Joe asked me about another
question one explain to mind shortly
after because was around how uh we're
obviously operating in interesting times
in public sector funding and as part of
the public sector family we're all
experiencing our own challenges but
um from a local government perspective
we interact with you around housing
delivery we interact with you around
Community transports not necessarily us
but certainly with aperture authorities
as social care and Mental Health
Services what impact is the local
government funding changes and
challenges having upon delivery of
healthcare services
it's all connected isn't it I think um
you and it always has been hasn't it it
tends to be that if if Health change is
something there is an impact a knock-on
impact somewhere else and vice versa and
I think just
um in terms of the impact we are all
having to assess that impact of of this
policies that are coming down from
government
um and that's why I think we're so
fortunate in North Devon to have one
Northern Devon that covers North North
and North Devon and Torrid and features
that so engaged with the business
Community because that gives you those
forms to talk about it and what tends to
what we've learned over the years of
doing this is if you focus on the person
that you're serving your customer
whether that's a resident or a patient
or a sister you know
um a member of Staff you tend to be able
to see a way of working through it now
it's not always possible but at least
you tend to see how your services
integrate and and the interfaces that a
patient experience or a service user
experiences and can you share any of
those resources so I know that uh North
Devon um
I can't remember sorry it's just names
just completely escaped me
um North Devon really value having R1
communities because that gives them a
that gives them that Community
engagement that and and sounds like
you've got exactly the same
infrastructure sharing that is just
really important isn't it so uh because
I think public expectations uh are going
to be quite difficult
um for all of us I think so
I hope that answers your question but um
yes thank you Sheriff one of the other
things to strongly was I think might be
doing a piece of work with North Devon
Council around housing Supply housing
delivery because yes future Workforce I
didn't know whether there was a
requirement to do this similar sort of
piece of work with us I don't know what
proportion of your Workforce uh North
them also lives lives in tourism
community
uh yes definitely um and I think uh we
understand that we need to give you
numbers so we need to tell you how many
key workers we've got how many students
we've got uh and the models by which we
um you know that's the one side on the
staff there's also
um we need to quantify some you know
supported living type accommodation as
well that we need so yes please to
engage in that it's probably not me but
it's definitely people in my
organization that that will pick this up
so that's great thank you
brilliant any other comments well I'm
sure it's really for you but um going on
what Zara said is it possible for our
committee to write a letter to our MP
about funding a human needing clarity
about them Hospital building you can go
ahead etc etc
uh it depends where you can't vote on
information
yes we will actively write to our local
MP to reiterate those comments that we
made and to support you thank you very
much
swiftly
any other ideas yes
about
um
[Music]
the time
foreign
[Music]
yeah
any other comments questions
[Music]
lovely thank you very much for taking
the time to come and present to us
tonight it's really interesting and um
from the personal positive feedback that
I've heard myself with people even like
getting Zoom consultations everybody's
like I don't know we would never use a
zoom computation but you know even my
elderly parents you can just sit back
and you know they think it's magic and
it's so much easier than actually
getting someone of 94 to where they need
to be it's like there they are they're
in their own their own Lounge so I think
maybe people have got that type of
support that can help me but it does
really work and it saves money energy
to earn time on both parties
so I I think it's there's a lot of
positive aspects to it so far hopefully
people will agree but thank you very
much for taking the time this evening
really interesting and um no doubt we'll
see you again yeah sure you will we'll
look forward to it thank you very much
thank you very much
um interesting
item number
none so consideration or plan
but it's blanket though
we don't know what we're all doing it
here but I mean I'm sure that you ever
see it in the next term there is lots of
lots of items to be covered in
particular I know we're not on Dentistry
that's a Langford so yes yes so um
there's lots there and
[Music]
um but time will tell from that one and
uh
item number 10 we don't have it first so
I think we can wind up a meeting
Absolutely I'll see you in a minute we
should uh North Carolina's going to be
added to the forward plan
yeah yeah
they are on there on the Autumn so those
on the bedroom will just fill the Cycles
hopefully whoever comes next
a bit well I'd like to take this moment
to thank you all for coming tonight
thank you for your support over the last
five months and to our office thank you
thank you thank you and thanks Jason
[Music]